ugh the holidays are finally upon us
which means it's the season for
cookies
welcome to the holiday cookie showdown
with us your favorite buzzfeed hosts
hannah and joyce four amateur bakers
will compete in unique cookie challenges
in order to crown the ultimate holiday
baker let the competition begin
[Music]
hi everyone it's joyce and hannah and
welcome back to our search for the best
holiday cookie baker in today's final
challenge our last two bakers will be
creating a candy cane inspired cookie
this baking competition is sponsored by
shipt the delivery service making the
holidays easier for all home chefs and
they brought over some amazing
ingredients for these cookies i can't
wait so let's welcome back our bakers
welcome back to the holiday cookie
showdown for today's challenge you'll be
making your favorite cookies with a
candy cane twist and again you'll be
judged based on taste presentation and
holiday essence so you guys know this is
your last chance to be crowned as a
champion of the holiday cookie showdown
i feel like last challenge you guys
really brought it i really felt the
holiday in your sweater but i want to
feel cold by that minty candy cane i
hope you have a good idea of what you're
gonna make because you're one hour
starting now
[Music]
today's challenge is to make a candy
cane inspired cookie and i'm making a
white chocolate dipped peppermint
chocolate cookie white chocolate chip
what it's a whole lot of everything oh
my gosh
i've never made a cookie like this
before with so many components because i
have to make sure the chocolate cookie
comes out well then dip it in white
chocolate and not forget to put the
candy cane bits on top too
today i'm making a candy cane pinwheel
cookie super hard a little ambitious
but i have a couple tricks up my sleeve
i've never baked with candy canes no no
oh oh my gosh this is gonna be tricky
i don't know what's going on with me i'm
struggling with this butter proportion
[Music]
this is half a cup
so embarrassing
this doesn't look like half a cup no
half a cup is the whole stick
i think
wait
luckily for me eliana speaks math so she
was able to come in and help me out
you're good oh
[Music]
i still cut it with scissors but
i was able to get it done
okay so first thing i'm doing is making
sure i get the dough ready because that
is to chill for 15 solid minutes and
once that's in the freezer then i get to
focus on making the chocolate but i
can't do it too early so it doesn't get
hard before the cookies are done so i
have this idea i want to make a candy
cane carousel because that to me is very
whimsical it's fun
so i need these cookies to be nice and
firm so i can build it up and just make
it a nice tall structure
everything went according to plan
kind of
and my dough is so
wet
as it's like flying everywhere
i'm not sure what's going on with the
room my hands it's hot
my dough does not seem to be meshing
well in the previous challenges it was
the same way so i'm having to add more
and more and more flour into it it's
like climate change is affecting the
dough as well
this is actually pretty lovely
[Music]
this is looking delicious
i'm gonna make this super red because
why not
[Laughter]
let's get this in and then
hope for the best
how do i make a frosting super hard put
more powdered sugar here we go
[Music]
i've just accepted it i'm like it is
what it is
[Music]
white chocolate is tricky so i'm really
happy it's melting well but i just try
to make it red oh no what are you using
your white chocolate for um and i wanted
a drizzle with red chocolate but now
it's just lumps i'm just ruining the
chocolate so i'm just gonna keep going
with my normal white chocolate but i am
adding a little bit of mint to give it
that extra something
wow
and i'm very impressed with my cream
cookie it's a peppermint what say it
again white chocolate dip peppermint
chocolate cookie
it's snow
[Music]
or paper bag
i feel like i'm right up to the wire but
i think it's gonna happen
[Music]
you did it benji yeah
guys so how did it go
pretty good
it was fun it was the most involved when
i think we were like down to the wire
well we're ready to taste yeah we've
been waiting impatiently for an hour
yeah i've literally just been salivating
for some cookies so eliana bring it on
down awesome
i'm feeling a little nervous because
benji's look amazing he made a whole
carnival carousel on a platter so i
really feel good about my cookies but
let's see what happens we'll see what
they think so these are crunchy
chocolate cookies but they're not just
chocolate they also are mint chocolate
and they're dipped in white chocolate
peppermint and i made you a little extra
stockings with your names on them
hope you like them you know i'm a scent
for my own name
beautiful cheers
holy cow
am i having a spiritual awakened through
a cookie
you know what's so good about these is
you say they're crunchy
the inside is so chewy mm-hmm
honestly i don't know i feel like this
cookie can literally slap me across the
face and i'm just really happy to be
here this is a good cookie and benji you
know what to do baby here i go
let's see
everything was pretty sturdy there was
no earthquake so everything was standing
up on its own my recipe was a candy cane
pinwheel
so i thought candy canes to me are very
whimsical so i wanted to make a carousel
and you know challenge myself to not
just do a pinwheel which you'll see at
the top one but candy cane sticks actual
candy canes brought the whimsical to the
scene i'm happy yeah it just makes me
feel like oh my gosh what is this i want
to eat it right now so what flavor is
the pinwheel
it's actually i tried to put um
[Music]
candy canes there's candy canes in all
the cookies
but it's basically a sugar cookie
i'm a little nervous because eliana did
have an extract
mm-hmm this is good mm-hmm
this is a well-made cookie mm-hmm thank
you
i really think you took a simple recipe
and you definitely reinvented it to be
your own i like how you did candy cane
inspired
without making it
too
minty i think these pinwheels look
incredible
the twisted candy canes could have been
a little cleaner mm-hmm
yeah i feel like oh my god i think it
might be over for me
we actually have a surprise for you
we have a guest judge
oh my god
oh my god this is the cutest little elf
judge i've ever seen in my entire life
elves like candy canes they love visuals
my cookie is super visually
aesthetically pleasing maybe by the
grace of the candy king gods i can be
saved
chocolate mmm
[Music]
[Applause]
the carousel
which one do you want to try
oh going for a candy cane
the elf kept going for the candy it
crunched down the candy that's cute and
all but my cookie like
there you go
heavy dipper wow
[Music]
you both came so far
you made so many delicious cookies there
can only be one winner of the holiday
cookie showdown
but the runner-up is
benji
i love what i do and it was a really
proud moment to see
under pressure what i was able to
accomplish
so eliana congratulations you are the
winner of the holiday cookie showdown
you really showed amazing technique
beautiful cookies just being on a baking
show is a dream come true and now it
happened and i won this is crazy
thanks for coming on this cookie journey
to find the best holiday cookie baker
with us fake your favorite holiday
cookie with the help of chips
i'm super fun
happy
holidays bye